hey youtube my name is Bruce or I'm
senior vice president and general
counsel of Intel Corporation and I
wanted to answer the question about
whether President Obama is likely to
improve the state of the world in 2009
quite simply I think the answer to that
is yes but you need to be a bit careful
with the metrics by which you're going
to measure success if we set the bar at
stemming the rising tide of unemployment
or putting liquidity back into the
banking system then I think it's still
far too early to say with any certainty
that we're going to see those kinds of
events in 2009 on the other hand if you
measure this or if to define success as
improving the relationship between the
American government and the rest of the
world or even more specifically
improving the relationship between the
American government and its own citizens
then I think the answer is a bit more
easy and perhaps even self-evident I'm
optimistic that we are going to sow the
seeds for improvement in 2009 but I'm
less sure that the world will be in a
position to reap that harvest within
just the next 12 or 18 months